in a city built on creating drama even a
burst water main it seems has to be just
that bit more spectacular in the middle
of Sunset Boulevard at one point water
shooting from the ruptured pipeline at
36,000 gallons a minute the road surface
unable to cope under the pressure the
only place for that water to go was
downhill and onto the campus of UCLA
flooding college grounds and pouring
into buildings students there captured
these images of the water surging into
an underground carpark and on roads
nearby cars stranded in the floodwater
a number of people were rescued from
vehicles as the level rose the sheer
speed with which it happened left even
fire crews struggling to cope and some
students decided it was too good an
opportunity to waste their boogie boards
put to good use the university's sports
fields were left looking more like lakes
and in the middle of rush hour part of a
city notorious for its congestion
brought to a standstill it took hours
for crews to shut off the water worried
that doing it too quickly would burst
pipes elsewhere the assessments of how
much it will cost to repair the damage
have only just begun
in the midst of their worst drought for
decades Californians have been desperate
for some relief this isn't what they
needed Gregg Milam Sky News Los Angeles